today i will set out the government's
approach to manage the impact of high
global gas prices affecting the uk
and countries
across europe
to begin
i want to make two points
extremely clear firstly mr speaker
i must stress
that protecting consumers
is our number one our primary focus
and will shape our entire approach
to this
important issue
secondly
i also want to reassure the house
that while the uk like other countries
in europe has been affected by global
prices
britain benefits from having a diverse
range of gas supply sources we have
sufficient
capacity and more than sufficient
capacity to meet demand and we do not
expect supply emergencies to occur this
winter there is absolutely no question
mr speaker of the lights going out or
people being unable to heat their homes
there will be no
three-day working weeks or a throwback
to the 1970s such thinking
mr speaker is alarmist
unhelpful
and
completely
misguided
to begin i'd like to set out mr speaker
some of the context for the global
situation
we are now witnessing
as the world comes out of covid19 and
economies reopen
we are seeing a dramatic uptick in
global gas demand much faster than many
people had anticipated high demand mr
speaker in asia for liquefied natural
gas
transported globally by freight
means that far less lng has reached
europe weather events uh in the u.s have
also affected lng exports to europe
so therefore increased demand coupled
with reduced
variety of supply globally has put
upward pressure on the price of gas
which is traded globally high wholesale
gas prices have subsequently driven an
increase in wholesale power prices with
a number of short-term
markets trading at
or near record levels
while we are not
complacent
we do not expect
supply emergencies this winter this is a
very important point this is not a
question of security of supply
the gb the great british
uk gas system has delivered securely to
date and is expected to continue to
function effectively with a diverse
range of supply sources and sufficient
delivery
capacity to
more than meet
the demand the national grid electricity
system operator has the tools uh within
itself
to to operate the electricity system
reliably to balance that system and we
remain confident that electricity
security can be maintained under a very
wide range
of scenarios
we aren't reliant on any one particular
source
for our gas like many of our
country our friends uh in europe
domestic production as uh members and
right honourable members should know is
our largest single gas supply source and
accounted for about 50 percent
of total supply last year however
the uk also benefits from an excellent
relationship with norway
one of our most important
and reliable energy partners and that
delivers nearly 30 percent
of our total gas supply just in the last
half hour mr speaker i was uh privileged
enough to speak to the norwegian energy
minister and to welcome the announcement
from equinor today that gas production
will significantly increase from the
first of october this year to support
the uk and european demand
our remaining supply mr speaker is
sourced from global markets via two
interconnectors uh to the continent and
also
through the lng
uh lng infrastructure which is as many
of you know as many members know is the
largest in europe
obviously the global gas situation has
had an impact on some of our energy
suppliers we've already seen
four suppliers exit the market in recent
weeks and we may well expect to see
further companies exiting the market
over the coming weeks i have to say uh
mr speaker at this point that having
been energy minister for nearly two
years before i became secretary of state
uh we saw in those two years uh around
this time companies exiting the market
it may well be more this year but this
is something which at this time of year
ahead of the renewable obligation
certificate payment uh this is something
which is often seen
in the market
i want to make it very clear today
however
that
this is not unusual it is not unusual
for smaller energy suppliers to exit the
market particularly i may add when
wholesale global prices are rising
the sector has seen as i've said regular
entry and exit over the last five to ten
years and that is indeed a feature of a
highly competitive market
the current global situation
as i've said mr speaker may see more
suppliers than usual exiting the market
but this is not something which
should be any cause for alarm or panic
we have clear processes in place to make
sure that all customers are supplied
with energy
when an energy uh supplier typically
fails mr speaker ofgem appoints another
supplier to take on serving the
customers and there is no interruption
to supply i reiterate our first and
primary consideration is for the
customer
i'd like to stress
three further principles
which are guiding my and the
government's
approach
in this matter firstly the government
will not be bailing out uh failed
companies there will be no rewards for
failure or mismanagement the taxpayer
should not be expected to prop up
companies which have poor uh business
models
and are not resilient to fluctuations
in price
secondly
customers
especially most particularly
vulnerable customers must be protected
from price spikes
and thirdly mr speaker
we must ensure that the energy market
does not pay the price for the poor
practices of a minority of companies
and that the market
still maintains
the competition which is a feature
of today's
current system we must not simply return
to i quote
the cosy oligopoly of years past where a
few large suppliers simply dictated to
customers
conditions and pricing
i'd like to reassure
all members and honourable members
constituents
that the energy price cap
which saves 15 million households up to
100 pounds a year
is staying
it's not going anywhere
as i said earlier our priority in this
situation has to be the consumer the
great british public and the cap
has done that
effectively it protects and has
protected millions of customers from
sudden increases in global prices this
winter we are committed to that price
cap and it will remain in place
meanwhile
sir
our warm home discount winter fuel
payments and cold weather payments will
continue to support millions of
vulnerable and low-income households
with their energy bills
it is absolutely vital that the energy
supply sector remains a liberalized
competitive market in order to deliver
value and good service
to consumers
as a result of high global gas prices
uh members and right honourable members
will have read perhaps
that two fertilizer plants uh shut down
in t side and cheshire last week they
suspended the production of co2 and
ammonia a decision
which has surely
has affected in the short term our
domestic supply
of carbon dioxide which as everybody
knows is used in the food and drink
and as well as the nuclear and health
sectors
yesterday i met tony will the global
chief executive
of cf industries we discussed the
pressures the business is facing and we
have explored quite thoroughly possible
ways to secure
vital supplies
work is ongoing across departments
in whitehall across the government
to ensure
that those sectors
which are impacted which are affected by
this
announcement have appropriate
contingency plans in place
to ensure
that there is indeed minimal
disruption
to maintain our domestic supplies
of co2 we are in constant
contact with relevant companies who
produce and supply co2 and we are
monitoring the situation
minute by minute
over the past few days
as has been widely reported i have held
several discussions with chief
executives of the uk's largest energy
suppliers and operators and also with
offgem to discuss this vital issue
just this morning i chaired a round
table with uk energy companies and the
representatives of consumer groups in
which i reiterated as i have done on the
floor of this house the need for all of
us
in government and across the industry to
prioritize to prioritize uh customers
in short to protect the consumer